welcome back thank you sir since you're
the one who's rested you'll leave it in
the bullpen yeah there's some nicotine
out there
what would the Republican reaction be if
a democratic president hid their health
from the public or pushed for their
physician to make false statements yeah
we didn't even get to that yeah oh
really that he wrote his own medical
report and gave it to his doctor like
that guy's a doctor I think the answer
the answer depends on the flammability
of Sean Hannity's hair we're so we're so
passed where the buses run on all this
stuff oh good I'm glad you're loosening
up and agreeing with me I don't bring
you around I've tried to save the
Republicans I know you are and you're
doing a hell of a job okay Matt does
libertarianism have a place to the in
today's political parties hell yes I'm
with the libertarian party first of all
I mean we're in an interesting moment
right now we're both major parties have
really retreated on stuff like
government spending like holding lye
non-interventionism against surveillance
warrantless surveillance and other
things like that I would also argue free
speech and so this the we need more
libertarian ideas in both parties and
also in the Libertarian Party I think
what does that look like in his
underwear a joke general how our NSA
operations being protected from a
president who leaks intelligence to our
adversaries so all right I without
arguing the premise all right right
here's the seriousness you carry Ohio
you carry Michigan you carry Wisconsin
you get the secrets and so if you got an
issue there you need to talk to the
voters yes not to the agency if it's so
depressing but but that's it wouldn't it
would be worse if he was interested it
would be worse if he actually read a
briefing or cared about anything except
whether you know Nordstrom is selling
Ivanka's shoes and that's one of the
challenges we have we have a president
Michael Gerson when a bush W
speechwriters said Donald Trump lives
the Eenie eternal now
little history no consequence the whole
job of intelligence is context and we
just fly by one time the long game yeah
exactly you know that's why we didn't
have a hot war and when we had a cold
war because it was fought by your people
yeah and that's a preferable way to do
it
all right is there a chance John that
current partisan divide could become so
irreconcilable that America plunges into
a second civil war I don't think so but
I wouldn't you rule nothing out he's
coming over tomorrow there you go
because historically we we did have one
I think it's more likely that there'll
be a reshuffling of the parties the
elements that belong to the parties
that's happened whenever there's been a
failure of consensus on the central
issue of the time so on slavery in the
50s and 60s on industrialization at the
turn of the century on the role of the
state then in the middle of century and
then chiefly in our own time the shift
from Republicans being the party of
Lincoln truly to the diamond the
Democrats being the party of
segregationist they got a stop saying
that the party of Lincoln you know party
switch well yeah a completely switch
that it's just ridiculous but but it's
there's nothing wrong with aspiring to
that now of course the case recently is
that they don't well the case right now
the case right now is that in 2016 it's
the first recorded case of a candidate
of a hijacker boarding a plane in the
passenger side with the hijacker and
that's what happened with Trump he took
over the base they got rid of the pilots
jeb Bush's and the great moral question
right now is who wants to be on the
right side of history as we were talking
about earlier and say this will not
stand
it's I love when Republicans say they're
the party of Lincoln like I love it I'm
like okay now could you act like it I
mean I mean it's just like when
conservatives suddenly are all worried
about women's rights and gay rights
right they bring it up so that they can
bash Muslims but then when it's actually
their own policies and actions they
don't do anything to uphold it but
they're like when it's convenient they
say it they use it as a fig leaf for
their otherwise racist behavior oh we're
the party of Lincoln it's sort of the
way George Bush remember when he was
talking about his National Guard service
I don't denigrate the guard well in his
day the guard was a way to get out of
the service and he took advantage of it
when he was president it was a way to
get sent to Iraq so he completed those
two okay so the question right now it
seems to me and it's good the Democrats
are gonna face it again with Sanders and
Warren and the Republicans are facing it
right now is the central issue is
globalization and its implications and
neither party as it stands has a
coherent answer to that and the races
and the xenophobia are all related to
the fact that people are worried that
immigrants are coming in undercutting
them the data is not very strong on that
of course which makes it all the more
hard to make an intellectual argument
about it right okay mayor as a young
Democrat do you think the party would be
better off if Nancy Pelosi announced she
would endorse a younger less polarizing
Democrat to be leader Speaker Pelosi our
House Leader Pelosi will retire when
it's time I think I've read this
automatic article that talked about how
a lot of the hate she gets is precisely
because she's a woman and then one with
power that she's been the most effective
party leaders ever so I thankful for her
leadership and everything she's done I
think when it's time I'm glad your stick
fire like that because like so many
Democrats
okay I think to the water point the
party does have to develop a [ __ ] oh
yeah but it's not just age it's Miss 'ti
it's it's sexual orientation that looks
like I think we're seeing that I mean
there are more women candidates than
ever this year bye-bye you know a
marginally that is yes all right thank
you everybody thank you audience we will
see you next week
[Applause]